in this video I'm going to talk about
what I think are the habits of a
successful software engineer so if
you're interested please stay tuned
first of all the habits that I'm gonna
list here apply to being a successful
software engineer not just a coder
software engineering is way beyond just
coding but that is a topic for a whole
new video let's get started when I first
started working in the field
I had an extreme urge to start coding
right when I was given a project a
problem a feature to implement because I
found that if I'm not coding I'm just
not being productive but the reality is
that most likely the software you're
going to be built in is not going to be
built fully by you from scratch you're
most likely going to be working on
something that needs to fit in into the
existent architecture and what
successful software engineers do is that
they first fully understand the scope of
the problem and only then once you fully
understand what exactly that you're Sol
then only then you should start coding
this brings us to point to successful
software engineers are really good at
documentation most likely you're not
going to be the only one working on the
project there might be other engineers
or designers or data scientists or
product managers involved and you need
to make sure that whatever is in your
head gets documented and then clearly
communicated for others a successful
software engineer will make sure to
document every stage of his or her
thinking of how they will approach the
problem what the solution of the problem
is what are the potential roadblocks to
the solution of the problem and they
will communicate this to all the
stakeholders and
is involved in this project they will do
that so that everyone is on the same
page and they will also do that to get
feedback from everyone most likely you
might have overlooked something and
asking for feedback and being receptive
to that feedback from everyone else is
super important the easiest way to get
that feedback is to get everyone on the
same page document everything for
everyone and that shared successful
habit number three successful software
engineers write readable code and they
do so because they understand that they
will probably not be the only person
interacting with whatever they wrote or
maybe after they wrote it there is going
to be someone else maintaining it
so they keep in mind the fact that
someone will have to come in and look at
this thing that they wrote that they
have never seen before and understand it
most importantly your solution your code
must be readable because someone else
might come in and want to understand it
successful habit number four is being
good at cross-functional work as a
software engineer you most likely will
work with other functions like design
Ares or product managers or data
scientists or people in operations you
name it a successful software engineer
empathizes with the other function that
they work with and almost put themselves
in that person's shoes so that they can
effectively communicate with them they
can deliver to them the exact
information that they need so if I'm
working with a designer I will try to
explain to them what exactly I'm
building from like the design
perspective if I'm working on a product
facing feature that's what I'm gonna be
focusing on in conversations with them
versus the actual nitty-gritty of
technical implementation if I'm working
with a data scientist I need to
effectively communicate with them about
log game or data analysis or just asking
them the right question about how we
want to analyze the data coming from
this new project or feature that would
build so being good at cross-functional
work is really important as a software
engineer and this brings us to my next
point
communication if you think that as a
software engineer you can just sit in a
corner not interrupt with absolutely
anyone you're definitely wrong of course
you should be setting your own
boundaries and communication style but
successful software engineers are
effective communicators successful
software engineers make sure that they
communicate clearly and effectively
especially if you work on a project that
involves other stakeholders or you work
with your teammates other software
engineers you need to make sure that you
communicate with them and over
communication a lot of times is much
better than no communication because
when you communicate or over communicate
you make sure that everyone is on the
same page you make sure that everyone is
clear on what you are working on and you
make sure that no one is wondering oh I
wonder what nobody's working on I wonder
if she completed that thing that I asked
her to implement a couple of days ago so
communicating effectively clearly and
potentially over communicating is
extremely important also by
communicating with your teammates you
can potentially recognize whether you
can help them out or you can unblock
them and communicate and in general in
your team indoor org in your company
just interacting with people can open up
opportunities for you you might hear
about something that another team is
working on that fits in or helps out
your products your team or your project
and that will open up opportunities and
doors for you next up recognizing
opportunities successful software
engineers recognize opportunities for
improvement and impact and what I mean
by that is that successful software
engineers do not just focus on their
projects or feature at hand that they're
working on but they're able to see
follow beyond bad they're able to follow
what their teammates are working on what
their orcs focus is and why that is
important is because when you're able to
see that big picture as opposed to being
very narrow focused on okay this is what
I'm working on and this is the only
thing I care about you're able to
potentially recognize opportunities for
impacts and improvements question why
people are doing things a certain way
you might learn new things that are
relevant to you you might also
potentially recognize what folds they
have in their systems and improve them
talking to people asking people what
they're working on thinking about how
their work fits in with what you're
doing doing where your team is doing are
great examples for recognizing
opportunities and last but definitely
not least is the growth mindset
consistently learning asking and being
open to feedback making sure you learn
from your mistakes and reflection are
all great examples of growth mindset
growth mindset is the difference between
thinking that your skill is absolutely
set and is defined by talent versus
thinking that you can learn and grow and
improve your skills and your growth is
defined by the amount of work you put in
to be a successful software engineer as
well as being successful in any
profession acts you must acquire the
growth mindset your skill is not fixed
you're constantly improving and learning
and you need to absolutely own that and
recognize that successful software
engineers are constantly learning
constantly asking for feedback in facts
feedback is also a huge thing if someone
has given you feedback to not be
defensive about it that means that they
really care for you to prove so you
should be open to understand will
learning and constantly recognize it of
what you could do better successful
software engineers are open to learning
are constantly open to growing are
absolutely okay recognizing that they
might be wrong guys thank you so much
for watching this video
I
hope you enjoyed it and I hope you
learned something new about habits of
successful software engineers if you
enjoyed it please don't forget to Like
and subscribe there is a subscribe
button down below and please leave your
comments down below as well
what do you think makes a successful
software engineer I would be really
curious to hear your thoughts obviously
what I mentioned is just a couple of
points in the myriad of things that
makes a successful software engineer but
please share your thoughts and I hope
you have a fantastic week bye for now